hey 42 here a lack of sleep is dangerous
we're often told not to drive whilst
tired and falling asleep at the wheel
can be fatal
during World War 2 many sleep-deprived
pilots fell asleep mid-flight and crash
their plane on the way home from the war
zone in fact you may be horrified to
hear that in a study 56% of consumer
aircraft pilots admitted to falling
asleep in the cockpit whilst a plane was
an autopilot it's fair to say that our
body needs sleep but how long could you
theoretically stay awake for could a
person die if they were forced to stay
awake for a long time and what happens
to your mind and your body when you miss
out on sleep let's find out
if you live to 78 you will have spent
around 25 years asleep but what if you
can't sleep well it's not quite as
simple as that because eventually your
brain will make you sleep after only a
couple of days years to sleep will
become greater than the urge to eat at
this point you might experience a
phenomenon as micros this is when your
brain forces you to sleep for a short
time without you being aware micro sleep
is a common symptom amongst insomnia
sufferers your brain suddenly shuts down
but your eyes remain open it can last
for a few seconds or a few minutes
during micro sleep the person's eyes
usually remain wide open but they will
have a blank distance there they will go
into a brief zombie-like state and won't
respond to any outside information you
probably experience micro sleep if
you've ever drove for a long period of
time on the motorway or highway on very
little sleep it's that feeling when you
blank out for a couple of seconds and it
feels like you've lost a brief period of
time but you don't remember actually
falling asleep as you can probably
imagine micro sleep is the cause of many
accidents micro sleep is your brains way
of going okay dude I know you're trying
to stay awake
a moment but I'm really tired you can
carry on as you are I'm just gonna go
catch a few Z's for a minute okay but
when it comes to wanting to sleep some
people don't have a choice a rare
genetic disease called fatal familial
insomnia or FFI prevents people from
falling asleep at all its effects around
just 40 families worldwide the disease
destroys the area of the brain that
controls when we sleep the following us
sufferers of ffs I will experience
progressively worse insomnia after a
while they start to hallucinate and
eventually they will become extremely
confused similar to dementia patients
and then they will eventually die the
average lifespan for someone with this
tragic and scary disease is just 18
months but even for the regular person a
lack of sleep can have severe effects on
the body and can even be fatal
after missing just one night of sleep
the first thing you will notice is a
decrease in cognitive function first and
foremost a lack of sleep impairs
attention concentration reasoning
problem-solving and your ability to
learn but perhaps what's even scarier is
that by missing out on sleep you can
wipe whole days from your memory it's
believed that during sleep our brain
consolidates organizes and permanently
stores that day's memories and what we
learned if you don't get enough sleep
instead of storing those memories
forever your brain will simply forget
them all together but that's only
scratching the surface continual sleep
loss over a period of several days or
more can have substantially worse
effects on your body chronic sleep loss
or insomnia has been linked to a
significant increase in heart disease
strokes diabetes obesity and depression
in fact a study showed that over 90
percent of people with insomnia also
suffer from some other serious health
condition
oh and sleep also keeps you looking
young it's during sleep that the growth
hormone is released that repairs tissue
keeping those wrinkles at bay when you
don't get much sleep specifically
slow-wave sleep your body doesn't get
opportunity to repair itself so you age
faster not only that but when you miss
out on sleep your body releases the
stress hormone cortisol which actually
breaks down skin collagen the protein
that keeps your skin smooth bouncy and
looking mighty fine sleep loss even a
few missed hours per night causes droopy
yellowish skin puffy eyes fine lines and
dark circles so now you know why you
really really shouldn't miss out on
sleep but how long could you
theoretically stay awake for if you were
forced to stay awake by an evil
scientist who stopped you to a chair
clockwork orange' style and gave you a
quick electric shock every time you
started to drift how long would it take
your body before it just gave up and
what would be the consequences the
answer to the question how long can
humans stay awake for is 264 hours or
about 11 days in 1947 a 16 year old high
school students in San Diego California
named Randy Gardner set the world record
for the longest scientifically
documented case of someone going without
sleep without using any stimulants
Dardanos stayed awake for 264 hours or
11 days before Gardner's attempt there
were many attempts to stay awake for a
prolonged period and since then there
have been many more the current record
holder is Tony right a man from the
South of England who broke Gardner's
record by just two hours staying awake
for 266 hours are you noticing the trend
here
almost everyone who attempted to break
the record hits a roadblock at around 11
days that seems to be the body's limit
in fact many researchers have attempted
to stay awake over the years and the
average period they reach is 8 to 10
days after which the urge to sleep
becomes far too overwhelming to continue
fighting against there haven't been any
recorded cases of someone staying awake
for longer than 11
consecutive days but if they did could
it result in death in the sleep
laboratory at the University of Chicago
an experiment was conducted on rats to
find out a sleep deprivation can kill
rats were put on a rotating disc which
was suspended over a pool of water
sensors were then attached to the rats
to record their brainwaves and the
computer program was set up to analyze
those brainwaves and detect when the
rats were about to fall asleep at which
point the disc would spin faster meaning
give the rats fell asleep and didn't
steady themselves on the rapidly
spinning disk they would inevitably fall
into the water below this harsh
treatment prevented the rats from
sleeping at all for risk of falling into
the water I know whose humans do some
rather horrendous things in the pursuit
of knowledge so was this horrific
experiment worth anything what did we
learn well all the rats that underwent
the experiment eventually died from a
lack of sleep the average lifespan of
the rats was 11 to 32 days the
scientists conducting the experiments
believed the cause of death to be
whole-body hypermetabolism a condition
which causes extreme weight loss and if
not remedied death the hyper metabolism
was most likely brought on by the lack
of sleep it's highly likely that if a
human were to stay awake for much longer
than eleven days then hyper metabolism
will kick in and cause ones eventual
demise or some other equally extreme
condition brought on by sleeplessness
although it's believed to have happened
at some point in history after all sleep
deprivation has been used as a method of
torture there has never actually been a
case well documented enough to study the
effects of forcing someone to stay awake
and so scientists aren't exactly sure
what would happen but just like rats the
general consensus is that if one were to
stay awake for much longer than 11
consecutive days
they most certainly would die the cause
of death wouldn't be sleeplessness
there's no such condition it would be
some horrific side effect brought on
from Knotts
for example hypermetabolism as was the
case with the routes
although the bodies urge to sleep is so
strong that this almost never happens so
there is very little evidence to be able
to know for certain what exactly would
be the cause of death at least in the
case of humans but just to be safe
try not to miss out on your precious
beauty sleep because if you do it enough
it very well could kill you thanks for
the view subscribe for more 42